all right marques Brownlee how's it
going good how are you doing well so I'm
curious I've followed your channel for a
while but I definitely did not follow it
in the beginning when you were reviewing
software on your laptop you've been
doing it for a long time what would you
attribute your success to on YouTube
well I do tech videos so I think that
the obvious answer there is Tech has
been interesting and important for so
long that just being in a tech space
generally for that long has has done a
lot for it yeah the channel itself I
mean there's plenty of other successful
tech channels but has its own unique
style as a consistent voice it's been me
for 10 years yeah so I guess just if you
combine all those factors consistency
plus tech staying interesting that's
that's mainly it mmm was there any
particular inflection point where it
really took off no I get asked that a
lot about like you know can I point to a
certain video or date or mother or
something like what happened to go from
like nothing to where it is now because
I've come to this day I look back and
it's mainly just like it you can look at
charts even it's just a sort of an
upward slope from 0 videos to a thousand
videos hmm you know it's obviously when
you get to certain points like the
reputa bility is that a word the
repeatability of the channel becomes
more significant so you're more likely
to subscribe to a tech guy with a
million subscribers talking about
something you should buy then a guy with
a hundred so that's helped but I feel
like if consistency again is major
really because yeah I mean I I follow a
couple subreddits on like weird YouTube
channels and there are people that have
a thousand videos reviewing elevators oh
yeah simple boring [ __ ] well I mean
there's there's always gonna be like
niche stuff which people will get really
into but I think like when when it comes
something as personal as a tech product
yeah you kind of want some sort of
history to go on or a sort of a
reputation to look back on when it was
like a thousand phones or a thousand
dollars now so yeah I think that's
that's helped being able to have a
history of stuff
and because in the beginning you were
just doing software right right for the
most part free software yeah and then
did you start getting phone sent to you
in like the early days of influencer
culture I remember early days pretty
well it was I started with all this
laptop stuff so the first stuff that got
sent to me was laptop accessories okay a
mouse a keyboard that kind of stuff some
some paid software I would get like a
key for $30 off a $50 piece of software
and I could have that access so that was
awesome okay phone stuff didn't happen
till much later I remember the first
event I ever went to was a Samsung event
in New York City where I met a youtuber
for the first time okay that was
probably like six years in so took a
while you were in it for a while yeah
you know I grew up getting like pirated
keys off LimeWire and all that kind of
stuff did you ever dip into that and
think like man maybe I should review
Final Cut Pro on mic at one point I
definitely did a whole hackintosh thing
oh you did which was definitely not
you know kosher I guess but you know
hackintosh world is a whole world so I
was curious about it and I got into it I
don't I was never really into like you
know downloading pirated music or any of
that stuff but I could imagine that was
its own world for a long time yeah yeah
because I I was curious because as a kid
you have no money when you're starting
out your channel yeah
and I wonder if you grew up with that
hacker ethos like like have you done a
teardown video before or anything like
that really I mean I was I used to be
much more into building pcs and taking
them apart upgrading them I had a Mac
that one that was the tower desktop Mac
Pro the g5 yeah I did like I was
replacing the GPU and upgrading the RAM
and all that and I had XPS tower had the
same thing too but I I guess I never was
really fully into the building process
as much as I was the final result okay
how well that finished product would
work for you okay but when I watch your
videos now you're pretty into the stats
of it all like all those like hard
metrics with the products right yeah
yeah
so it attracts you in some way yes I
mean I think if you just look at if you
take a huge step back and just look at
what the videos are about period
especially with the reviews it's like
how good is this product that this
company made going to work for you
and there's a whole bunch of different
ways to measure that I'm trying to
measure that so so what are the what are
those metrics like what's the I've heard
you talk about it before in the context
of like this is a feature that's gonna
maybe like spark some interests and this
is a feature that I'm gonna use every
day
yeah like gimmick versus daily yeah yeah
that's one way I mean I kind of you can
pick up a phone and use a really cool
feature for two seconds you're like whoa
that's amazing
but when you actually buy the phone are
you gonna use that feature I'm kind of
trying to evaluate that yeah there's all
sorts of benchmarks and things people do
like how fast is a storage how much RAM
does it have how fast is this chip and
that stuff is useful obviously if you
have more demanding needs for your phone
but a lot of it is literally just
evaluating like is this a gimmick or is
this really gonna be daily driver
material one thing I was talking about
on a recent podcast is is how it's very
hard for the market to to recognize how
good a product's quality is like just
that actual feel like when you sit when
you touch an iPhone for the first time
yeah right and so like how do you go
about quantifying that when you're
making video I mean it's really
sometimes I see my job is like a
professional user like I really just
have to use it and so you get the the
briefing obviously and the breakdown of
all the new features and what is new
versus what's not new and you can
compare it to things you've used before
but at the end of the day like you
actually have to use it to figure out if
it's actually useful yeah yes there's
all kinds of use cases there's they'll
tell me about a new feature and they'll
tell me exactly there's some new york
for you yeah oh how it like the ideal
use case scenario how it works well this
came up recently because i did a video
with an LG phone that came out has this
feature where you wave your hand over it
and do these gestures to open up apps
and things like that it's called the g8
okay and like on the surface like
this is cool this is like future type
stuff but then you actually use it
you're like alright so I don't know what
I have stuff on my hands maybe I'm
cooking but I just want to like open the
YouTube app real quick and search for
something like now what like I have to
still type in what I want to search like
this there's a there's limits the
usefulness of that so that for me fell
on the gimmick bucket just because using
it actually changed my mind but then
what about the features where you
thought it was great and that didn't
catch on are there examples of that well
there's there's lots of examples of
things that are great to me that aren't
a big deal to other people like imma I
love high-resolution really nice screens
and you can hand you can hand me a phone
with a 1440p AMOLED great display and
you could hand me a phone with a 1080p
LCD display and I'd look and I'd
immediately want the better one yeah
but to an average person a lot of times
whatever like that they both look fine
to me is one one of them's bigger I like
the bigger one so sometimes there will
be things that all evaluate I'll be like
you've got to get this because it's got
a great screen and it won't matter to a
lot of people yeah but at least then you
can calibrate yourself to what I've in
the past liked a lot so in the past I
keep saying like I really like these
phones because of their screens and you
know from the your past experience that
screens aren't a big deal of you then
you can at least say ah right out I'll
discount this point because screens
aren't my thing okay yeah because I've
kind of wondered if we're going to reach
a point of complete diminishing returns
with smartphones right like oh man you
know iPhone 10 or whatever like this is
awesome
iPhone 11 is it a hundred percent better
unlikely right yeah do you think we're
gonna reach peak smartphone eek
smartphone it's a common question yeah I
don't okay and because and the only
reason I don't is because I've heard
that question for the past like five
years of smartphones and then the next
year I'm like oh that's new and I think
it's mostly because the trends change
like there was a thinness trend a couple
years ago where it was like we got a
nine millimeters thin and then 8.9 and
then 8.1 and then 7.9 holy crap there's
a six millimeter thin phone have we
reached peak smartphone
and then it changed to like okay now we
want these bezel responds the thickness
whatever it's it's just gonna be thin
that's just the way it is but now can we
get a 90 percent screen to body ratio
can we get this knotch smaller can we
get 93% 95 eventually we're gonna be
like have we hit peak like we got the
whole screen yeah and then the next
trend is gonna happen I don't know what
that next trend is but I feel like
because of I've observed these cycles
over the past couple years it doesn't
seem likely that it's just gonna we're
gonna get this end product of like the
perfect phone I mean maybe well be great
yeah but yeah I don't I mean I know a
lot of people are holding on to you know
iPhone basically five form file that's
definitely true phones are better and
they last longer
yeah than they ever did so in that sense
we're closer to peak smartphone because
your iPhone if you buy an iPhone 10s now
that phone's probably gonna be good for
like four years like legitimately iOS
has gotten better so it's true you can
hang on to an older phone longer thing
you used to be able to you yeah but uh
that's also something tech companies got
to think about when they make their next
product yeah yeah so what do you make of
these new trend like some folding things
like new trends right now there's a lot
of folding one is is one of those
interesting ones cuz I I'm trying to
imagine the future of like why folding
phones matter uh-huh at this point like
generation 1 folding phones I like
alright proof of concept like if you can
technically fold it but there's a big
ugly crease in the middle on these
bezels are huge and you know it's it's
not really it doesn't seem that useful
yet okay but that challenge is to like
okay go like eight nine years down the
road where it's like oh yeah you can
just you have a tablet and a phone and
you just unfold your phone and becomes a
tablet like in that world it was worth
it like to 2019 folding phones were
worth it because we got to that point
yeah so if we get to that point someday
then I think okay I'd be worth it but
okay so so then I've noticed you filmed
a bunch of Tesla videos right based on
you know the ratio of types of content
on your channel are you just betting
electric vehicles that is the next big
trend partially yes and partially I just
love the thing yeah I mean but
like a cool signal right like I remember
people wouldn't shut up about their
iPhones when they got them and the same
thing is true for the Model S yes and
that's that's a comparison I've heard
like the Tesla is the iPhone of cars
again like it's kind of just that that
next wave an electric does seem like
it's future you see all these big
companies like yeah we're gonna go
electric by 2028 like it's great someday
yeah no I'm a huge fan of the Tesla and
it's like it's kind of like a perfect
segue into me I've always been into cars
but like I'm 25 like I went to cars
could I be I don't drive all kinds of
cars and stuff but the Tesla was a
perfect Segway into cars because it's a
tech product yeah it has all these tech
features it's basically a tech company
so it was sort of a natural segue into
the car world yeah cuz I've just been
curious like on the performance side how
much it actually matters cuz if you look
around you know obviously the Model S is
nuts Drive right yeah
but then you know the Prius is have
you've driven a Prius before yeah not
the most exciting it works
gets you there yeah right and so yeah
I've been kind of wondering where the
eview market will end up going because
the model 3 is also pretty quick yeah
yeah but you know yeah but what's your
impression of like the low-end UV market
the thing about UV is you still get like
that quick torque so even though the
performance from like you know you're 60
to 90 might not be like high-end gas car
territory most of the acceleration and
like merging and quick things you do on
a TV even a low-end DV is still like
zippy like you still feel like you're in
that like zippy go-cart type of feel
even in like I drove a model 3 when it
first came out and so it was rear-wheel
drive I'm pretty sure the 0-60 is like 5
and a half seconds or something which is
fine but like the car felt quick ok like
I'd step on the pedal and I felt like
zippy like I was in Model S so even
low-end V's will have that feel and
that's attractive to people um I think a
lot of people over rate how much sound
matters like in the high-end car market
everyone cares how their car sounds but
for you know 90% of people who are
interior or the actual engine so yeah
the engine sound ok
like when I hit the pedal I want to hear
it working
for me like that's a common like
resistance to the Eevee's so but yeah I
think for like 90% of people or taxis or
just commuter vans or just basic
transportation like silence is great huh
and in terms of features within the car
they tend to be ahead yeah I think I
mean maybe I'm just because I'm looking
mostly at Tesla but like the amount of
things you know having a smartphone
controlled app where you can summon the
car to you like all these these remote
start/stop features and gas cars are
great but when you look at the amount of
I mean Tesla's tech companies you see
all kinds of tech features yeah yeah
yeah I guess I just kind of wonder like
where because you spent so much time
reviewing products both like smart
phones and cars and stuff like you kind
of get an impression of the bleeding
edge but I'm wondering like where you're
you're seeing it going like things that
are just popping up where you're like oh
that's that's actually a super cool
feature that people aren't talking about
or thinking about right now in the
context of cars I mean honestly just
going electric and the number one thing
you think about it's charging how do you
charge it like how fast as a charge how
long is the battery last things like
that those basic questions the more like
those big companies think about
answering those questions like Ford and
like Chevy and those big guys yeah the
more you realize how how far ahead
Tesla's but how how much how far there
is to go to actually make v's useful for
most people but I think you know the
basic premise is you're just going a
lecture click right you just put a
battery in it you charge it and you
drive it the same way a normal car dress
but I don't think there's any sort of
magic sauce to it other than that you
just kind of have to get so it's so it's
more like on the infrastructure side
it's really important getting it on yeah
this is less flashy and like you know
magic feature that's winning the market
over but it's like that's what you have
to nail to make a good Evie mmm okay and
so you know now you're you said you're
25 yeah so now that you're 25 do you
feel like there's gonna be a point where
you have less of a pulse on like the new
I'm so scared of that
yeah I'm 29 and I'm like oh no do you
feel that at 29 like I don't know it's
I'm scared of being that that like old
guy he's like out of touch like but at
least at least I think that process
would be slower for me because I I'm so
immersed in it now yeah
like with music maybe I'm already there
like music new music comes out of that
like I tried to listen to like the
Billboard 100 okay like whatever the
other day and I was just like this is
objectively bad like I can't I can't do
this clearly I'm out of the loop but I
guess with tech I don't know maybe I'm
I'm a little more immersed so that might
take longer yeah or it's just near and
dear to your heart so it really matters
yeah I'll just uh well there's also hope
because there are plenty of money much
older you know tech journalists and
techie youtubers or who are doing the
thing so I mean if you if you stay like
in that world it's it's kind of just
part of what you're doing every day no
and I know plenty of older people who
are way more into music than I am and I
catch things early yeah but it is this
like core fear as a you know creative
person where you're like dude my yeah my
old school right now am I out of it yeah
yeah yeah so do you uh does that fear
like motivate you to try like weirder
YouTube stuff or are you like kind of
you know this kind of phone whatever
video works and I'm just gonna keep
banging it out I don't know yeah I mean
I'm definitely trying to diversify the
kind of breadth of coverage you might
call her I don't think that's out of
fear of like forgetting what's popular I
think that's just cuz like I'm
interested in other things there's other
ways to talk about them so there's a
reviews and there's smartphone stuff but
there's also the car videos now which is
the autofocus series but there's also
like I'm into production naturally
because that's what I'm doing all the
time so I'm doing this this whole like
spaces series where I'm I'm talking
other creators and how they use their
space
I'm ideally starting a podcast pretty
soon where I can just talk with people
about things like this so there's I
think that just comes from like all the
other things that I've become interested
sit in of course through you know making
tech videos interest so what else would
be the on the podcast I want to talk to
other creators yeah it's like probably
in the main thing because that's not
something that is readily available to
me I think like when you get to a
certain a certain place in this creative
world there's no longer like a article
you can go read to figure out how to do
something like when you're starting
YouTube you can figure out like what's
the best DSLR for a thousand bucks and
buy it and find the lens that works best
with it and then start from there but
like what I'm trying to figure out like
hmm how do i best like start a new
series given the current uploads and
like the pace of you know the way things
are moving like all these nuanced
questions that don't necessarily have
answers but that other creative people
think about to you just talking with
people about that kind of stuff hmm yeah
I mean it sounds a lot like just
strategy right we're like 10 things can
simultaneously be true but you have to
pick one
yeah and that that can be a little
intimidating I guess and help yeah so
like it's less math more just like I
don't know it's just strategy
yeah strategy and like creative insight
yeah yeah and so what are you going to
try and like innovate in your podcast
and anyway cuz I'm what I'm kind of
fishing for is like you know obviously
YouTube video right like what are the
other mediums that you're like testing
out to feel like I hope maybe there's an
audience here like maybe I can break
ground here yeah I feel like video as a
medium is my favorite by far mm-hmm so I
think I don't think about new mediums as
much as I think of new ways to do video
new topics new formats within video
podcasting being like a sort of an
auxilary way to to also talk as a big
speed I don't know that is big speed
I've never even heard it in real life
and I've never intentionally triggered
bixby so that's like the third or fourth
time that it's thought I've been talking
to it where was I oh I mean video yeah I
I think I'm still trying to figure out
the whole video thing generally and that
might be a battle I never win but I feel
like that's that's gonna be taking up
most of my time this is doing different
types of videos okay okay and so it have
you tried 360 have you tried VR like
have you tried these new formats
I have tried one I've published one 360
video okay one that I thought was a
really good idea it was a studio tour so
it would be like you're sort of moving
around the studio but you can also look
around and see what's behind you and
around you so we sort of feel like
you're in that space that's a good use
of VR and that was fun but that was one
of those things where like I struggled
to find other genuinely productive uses
for it in my in my case yeah it's
awesome for games I love it for games I
love for other stuff but for video it's
been sort of a head-scratcher well it's
very we did a podcast with Jessica
brillhart who's a VR creator and I New
York and it's a difficult storytelling
challenge because like with film you're
inherently like controlling the
viewpoint of our audience yeah and with
games losing explore right exactly so
very like natively fits in but even just
like the prep involved in like shooting
a 360 video like right now there's a
bunch of like wires and [ __ ] dangling
all over the place it's no big deal when
the camera can control that exactly yeah
that's another challenge I mean the the
rig we used was really cool like we
could have yeah basically like you it's
not like literally following me around
but it went from place to place and we
had a couple setup places around the
studio so the video would move between
these places and you could follow me
around but yeah that's like that to me
was like peek 360 like I figured it out
this is the best use of the 360 in like
a real estate yeah
but outside of that yeah it's been like
maybe a car maybe it just tours in
general like a lot of car stuff is sorry
because it's such a small space maybe
getting a smaller rig in there where you
can sort of look around as if you're in
the car that's tough yeah but do you
feel limited by cameras in any way at
this point only slightly okay I feel
like I'm like not even allowed to
complain because the cameras I user so
scene but on occasion I wish the camera
had autofocus I wish the camera was
smaller I wish the cameras battery
lasted longer but those are like pretty
minor things as far as I can still get
the image I want and then really if I
work hard enough you don't have
autofocus on all your cameras
I don't really yeah just the lens or the
actual camera the camera essentially it
has a really really poor autofocus
system but it's a it's a red camera and
no one uses autofocus for red cameras so
they don't really work on it so it's not
good
so it's manual focus all the time and
that has its downsides obviously
especially when we're doing car stuff
trying to do fixed focus car stuff when
the car moves all this hierarchy there's
a lot of weird things with fixed focus
but we've we've messed with rigs where
we can do remote follow focus stuff and
all kinds of other hacks to get around
it okay but yeah that's like one of
those hundred things do you do much
drone stuff a little bit for cars it's
funny because we I always wanted to do
drone stuff but for the longest time I
was mostly doing like handheld gadget
yeah so it felt like what do I need is
drone for I like it's just gonna fly
away from me holding an iPad like that's
not that compelling but now that we're
doing car stuff yes there's plenty of
use for drones okay have you mounted
anything to the hood I don't like those
giant Gimbels have you tried that out
yet we've gone we've gotten a little
into that like we have this whole I
guess we're always trying to make you
know setups for scenarios yeah and I
think the next scenario setup we're
working on is like the chase car how do
you shoot a car from any angle you want
from another car so you can obviously go
out the side because there's a window or
you can get a sliding door we can't we
shot out the back so we have the lift
gate go up when you can go like hold a
gimbal out of the back but shooting the
back of a car in front of you is hard
because there's a sloped windshield so
it's distorted so do you hang out the
side of a thing or off axis so there's
kind of a weird problem with shooting
the back of a car okay that's like one
of those things were working on I guess
putting something on the hood would be a
way to shoot a car in front of you but
then you're fixed in your height so you
can't really go low so then there's
those camera
cars that have a jib on top of it you
can go all kinds of angles so that might
be fun but as of right now that's pretty
early yeah this is this is a funny
creator problem because industry people
have figured this out oh yeah yeah like
if you see like professional you know
like Tesla shoots like they got it
locked down yeah absolutely
but like marques individual YouTube guy
like just to fly to LA and like film on
the PCH yeah the question is like how do
you do that and so that those are the
kinds of questions that you're curious
about yep
okay yeah and there's not like a
youtuber Network where you just like
call call up what airs I mean there are
YouTube friends that also have similar
questions like we can talk about it all
you want
I've had a couple friends who are
obviously in LA cuz that's where almost
everyone is play and we talk about gear
all the time and like production
strategy in a way like how do you shoot
these things we've collaborated on one
of the last things we did was when we
interviewed Ilan we did a factory tour
yeah which was like how do you shoot a
factory tour with like two people
walking through it do you just have one
person hold the camera while you're out
or do you have a person next to it you
know that's like that was a whole thing
or we figure out how to do that but yeah
and the industry's got it all locked up
yeah but it's also I think what what a
lot of people could get from you is like
storytelling techniques because that at
the core of it like obviously the
products are cool right but like you're
a storyteller - yeah and so when you're
gonna go and do an interview with Ilan
and I saw most of your interviews like
10 minutes 15 minutes long yeah right I
assume it's cut down - yeah yeah and a
lot of it also is cuz they're really
busy people yeah that's just it all the
time that we get with them and it all we
have but yeah that's like a it's like a
happy medium of talking a little longer
than a five-minute video yeah which is a
nice format for YouTube like we've tried
both and I mean I'm so impressed with
Rogan he's like three hour videos and
people are into it yeah so when you
think about like okay I'm maybe we
should do the product scenario right
like how do you think about storytelling
in the case of a review
context so what came before it well came
next to it what it's up against and
momentum in a way so it's like a new
phone comes out you naturally compare it
to the phone that came before it and
then you compare it to other phones
around it and how much those step
forward versus how much it steps forward
and now right there it can be an enough
of an interesting story for a lot of a
lot of devices that come out I remember
when iPad pro came out yeah that story
was like iPad was already so far ahead
in tablets and then iPad pro took a
massive step forward versus the last
iPad like this is obscene how how much
like there is no other $1300 tablet I
would even consider like that's alone in
its category which is really fascinating
so yeah I guess those two things like
the context of other products that exist
next to it and what came before it
okay and when it comes to storytelling
of you as a person like expanding it
like all the gross words like personal
branding on yeah where do you go like
how do you tell your story and then how
do you fit in what your future plans and
hopes are I guess I kind of I do less of
that because I consider tech the star of
the show okay I think I do inject my own
personal humor or perspective on
occasion just because it's it's fun and
keeps it interesting and that's its own
challenge but I've always considered
tech the star of the show and any way I
can I try to make that the main story
interesting and so that will just
continue to drive future projects for
you yeah I mean the the one string that
ties everything together is it's coming
from me so it's always the same
perspective so like when you see a new
car video like it with top gear for
example you know that guy's driven these
cars before so he's gonna think of it in
the context of all those other cars okay
so when I do a car video you know I'm
gonna compare it to the other four or
five cars I've driven which are electric
so like that's
that's the difference between you know a
car video from me and someone else but
at the end of the day the car is this
thing is the thing like that's what I'm
talking about and sharing with people
but I I guess I'm probably under waiting
how important my own personal voices but
I I really try to make the tech the star
of the show well I think it's it's the
focus in your video I appreciate the
modesty look but like there are how many
million YouTube channels with people
reviewing phones true that's real great
yeah so you sit out in some way so you
got like a hundred plus questions from
Twitter so I want to answer some of them
we're gonna skip the the middle initial
for 10 million subscribers yes yes yes
of course
but there are a lot of best practices
around YouTube you may have answer these
before but Marco Castro asked what
advice you have for new creators on
YouTube new creators ah new creators
being pretty broad because you can be a
new creator and tech or a comedy or a
new photographer you know there's all
kinds of new creators but on YouTube
generally like if I was starting over
today yeah I would kind of do a lot of
what I'm doing now which is like you
take your inspiration from other places
but you always have to come back to your
own voice in your own perspective don't
try to be something else that already
exists or there won't be any reason to
watch it it already exists so find your
own new angle your own new voice your
own new way of showing or or talking
about things yeah and and then get
started and a lot of it just comes to
luck and YouTube's kinda saturated yes
the consistency is very important when
do you think you found your voice as a
creator I think super early really I've
always been like I want crispy video I
want high quality I know what I want
like I think that came at the very
beginning even when I was oh man doing
these tutorial videos yeah I watched a
couple they're fun ok I'm sorry
I love gone like you went through
puberty on you to essentially yeah
yeah there's all these I did all these
tutorial videos which are just
screencasts it's just my screen at a
mouse moving and I was obsessed with
getting the highest frame rate possible
and the smoothest motion blur of my
cursor on the screen in a like that it's
so stupid but like I've always wanted
that production to facilitate the story
as best as possible
I want the quality to be like as
realistic as it can be so that it's not
a distraction yeah and that's still the
way it is like I might put up with a
whole
almost like schtick is like overproduced
like really going in under Lois and
there's a lot exactly overly realistic
but to the point where like if you look
at this video on your screen you'll feel
the closest to actually holding it in
real life like that's the goal so I
think that I don't know if that's my
voice or just my style but I found that
to be a priority pretty early well I
think it's kind of a combination right
because you both you have your taste
which I think the world has decided is
good sure and yeah and then just you're
like hardened opinion that this is gonna
be super high quality right right and so
did you grow up with these like values
given to you or is it a personal thing
you just were born with ah I guess it
must have been instilled in me in some
way I mean I've always been into tech
and and tech has always had a like an
emphasis on like we're the best we're
the high that's good I like hardcore
like this is the highest quality
mentality it's a great question I guess
I guess it's just what I decided I
wanted at some point and I've really
thought about that it's it's just it
seems like it would be everyone's goal
when I think about it like striving for
the highest quality production it was a
no-brainer to me and I guess it's when
you end up in the position where you're
able to you know use really high-end
equipment and like you can make more of
what you want because of the position
you're in
yeah it's even more of a no-brainer
because the barrier is lower but I guess
yeah that that challenge
to to make like the perfect video is
like so the air quotes for audio
listeners like that's that's always
probably gonna be a moving goalposts
yeah you're always reaching for it and
it's always slipping away
but there's something innate in you
right and I think in a lot of people who
are maybe I wouldn't go so far as always
calling people perfectionist but to like
want to do it over again and over again
and over again until it's just right
that's the thing that's the thing that
creators have to overcome and that a lot
of times you don't want to you like if
you end up like I would consider myself
borderline like perfectionists and some
stuff I remember doing like SAT stuff
where it was like okay you have to write
this essay you're gonna get the topic
and like you have to write it right then
like I want to think about this for a
couple days before I actually put a pen
to paper and like you just have to spit
out three pages and hopefully it's good
enough like that's kind of the way
YouTube is like a new phone just came
out go like you don't get to sit on this
for a while like you you form the best
thing you can and if it's 95% there and
it's done that's better than 99% there
and still working on it
that's a that's a barrier for me like I
wish I could take more time with a lot
of stuff but tech just moves fast so you
just kind of have to evolve your your
production and ideally make the best
thing you can and you you follow your
your listeners you follow your gut when
it comes to making choices like is that
is there like a data-driven approach to
what kind of videos you're making mmm no
it's I'd say it's almost no data at all
it's I mean you get you yeah you get you
have comments of people who are like
this part of the video is cool I enjoyed
that or or like a you could have spent
more time on
I wish you'd gone into this more or I
was wondering about this and I'm glad
you addressed it like certain things
like that okay um were and I guess the
only data it comes down to is like I
made a six minute video on this phone
but I left out these three things
I wonder if an eight minute video would
have been watchable like knowing you
know all the other things that go into
YouTube and retention and and how long
people watch and the attention span of
the Internet I guess that's all data but
at the end of the day I'm just like
I guess yeah I probably could have
included that or maybe I didn't have to
go into that much detail about this new
camera it's almost the same as last year
yeah like that kind of stuff Wow
12-minute video could have been nine
minutes and said almost the same thing
information density is my my like
writing challenge I'm trying to fit as
much structurally sound information
that's like follow able to most people
as possible which in tech is I don't
know if that's more or less of a
challenge probably more well it's it's
tough to decide what's most valuable to
people that's mainly it like I a lot of
people will the best comments you get
really or that I get are from people
who've never seen the videos before and
a lot of times they'll say oh you know
these are videos for like the mainstream
[Music]
buyer like not for the hardcore tech
person but all the information that goes
into saying those top-level things the
way I said them came from all the depth
of using the device and all the hardcore
stuff that I left out so in a way it
feels like oh I should just include
everything so that they know that I'm
like really into what I'm talking about
yeah I'm with you I swear but it it
becomes less presentable that way it
becomes verbose that way like I can say
the same thing five different ways but
the shortest most succinct complete way
is usually the best way so that's what
I've been trying to do that's kind of a
mark of someone who really knows what
they're talking about - like if you can
teach it to someone who's ten years old
it's true then you can explain it it's
also the selling point of a lot of great
companies you know Apple absolutely
almost all right before we go more into
the YouTube questions Matt dude how do
you deal with YouTube comments um I've
it's I think people really hate YouTube
comments and for whatever reason it
hasn't been that bad for me okay now I
can't say lately meme culture has made
its appearance in my comments section
far more often in the past couple months
for an unnamed reason yeah I'll just say
it's Will Smith's fault but
I think the the comments section has
actually been pretty helpful and pretty
great for me for the past couple years
and whether that's like because I kind
of I can also separate the comment
section into kind of three categories
our one of upload which is like useless
it's mainly just people saying either
first or reacting to the title and
thumbnail and not actually watching the
video or just like getting something in
to hopefully get a response like the
first hours not really very useful then
there's like our 2 through 24 which is
like people watching a video and being
somewhat thoughtful before leaving what
I'd consider a useful comment and then
there's people who are finding it in
search so this is no longer subscribers
this is people who were looking for
something about this device found this
video clicked it hoping for something
and left a comment based on what they
watch those are the most useful comments
so if you can divide that like if all
your reading is the first three hours of
comments or like this is useless I hate
YouTube comments yeah but if you can
sort of stitch those out into like
what's coming from what audience then it
can actually be somewhat productive I
think for huh yeah I always I always
struggle with the personal attacks yeah
yeah I think I think they just kind of
get drowned out and that's probably
another benefit of where the channel is
like yeah people just bury that stuff
Oaks is pretty great
that's great yeah and you didn't get it
when you were a kid I definitely did and
I ignored it oh go with a thick skin
from that and and now it's just kind of
it probably still exists and I just
ignore it that's [ __ ] awesome ok so
Austin Ryder asks in the early years of
the channel Marcus took a several month
hiatus from YouTube but then came back
with a new video format and seemingly
renewed Drive what happened during those
months off that's a great very dedicated
that's a very few people know that that
was when I was in high school and that
was my senior year and I just had to
finish get my grades up college
applications the last year of ultimate
like three days a week practices for
hours like that was just like I don't
have time
I want to make videos so bad but if I if
I do I'm gonna get in that rabbit hole
again and I'm gonna try to make five
videos a week and I'm just not gonna
have the time for the things that matter
right now so that was the end of high
school where I was buying to colleges
going to all these things and interviews
and pre-college and and all this stuff
SATs the whole deal okay um and a
renewed drive was just exciting I was
like hell yes I'm back five days a week
let's go College no schedule I'm in it
yeah minute yeah that was that was a
pretty good time okay
right on a bunch of people ask the same
question
Winston asks what's your daily schedule
because I'm particularly curious because
you also maintain a level of fitness for
ultimate yeah yeah I practice last night
my daily schedule so I kinda I would
separate into weekdays and weekends okay
weekend a week days I guess are divided
again into production days or pre
production post production day's
production days are filming editing the
meat of of making videos and writing
especially and pre production or
post-production days are more of like
the inbox the strategy the what comes
next the travel all that sort of stuff
that comes in between the videos and
then there's nights which are either
like the leagues I play in or practice
or so I play for the Pearl Ultimate Team
for New York we had practice last night
on Randall's Island it was cold so cold
and then weekends are ultimate I don't I
don't work on weekends and that used to
be a thing I would just work in between
frisbee but frisbee happens on weekends
so that's traveling that's playing
that's resting that's like disconnected
from the internet type stuff and so you
train by practicing yes there's no like
other regimen
I'll gym in my basement I like ask ask
anyone who's like around me a lot I'm
usually there at night okay
but as far as like like playing a lot
that's kind of the best training you can
get yeah that's right spend so in your
Jim what are you doing squats what are
you doing
I have a bike I have the treadmill but
then I have a lot of free weights I
believe in free weights I don't have
that many machines so it's mostly just
yeah the dumbbells and the I don't even
know that the bar is called that Oh
Karla murse now you're standing in it
and it's just to do dips and stuff to do
squats or to do dang I don't know the
names of any good deadlift like when
yeah like a deadlift oh no that was
called hexagon thing yes that then Devon
seems like it I'm sure that's why it's
called a hex bar X bar yeah you got a
hex bar yeah sure that's some pleats so
yeah that's that's like some of the time
but then eventually you you just have to
throw and I don't want to get into like
ultimate advice but like I said you a
scar on your hand is that ultimate
really it is ultimate related I in
college went to go lay out to get a
defensive play and I on the turf skidded
forward and snap my finger in half so I
had I got a little plate and screws in
there now fix that bone strongest bone
in my body now reinforced that's great
yeah I got that
screws my shoulder I feel the same way
yeah yeah all right
I'm ed Kahn asks are there any problems
that you see your face that you really
wish engineers or developers would solve
engineers and developers and then we're
kind of on it they're kind of on it a
lot of times there's like the beginning
like folding phones for example like you
kind of see the beginning of like some
potential and I like all I hope they go
all in on that that could be really cool
in the future but generally like it's
all being worked on I wish some of it
was being worked on more than it is I'm
reviewing a lot of phones right now
whose cameras are just not close to the
pixels camera in particular and I know
they could get closer I know they could
put a little more into that but they
don't and that's their own choice and
their own priority but they totally
could so stuff like that that's just
like things that I prefer in some
devices I wish were were more of a
priority but generally I think we live
in a pretty good world nothing really
sucks anymore you know like the tech we
use
even at the lower end just kind of works
pretty well ya know it's very salt I
haven't upgraded my phone for that
reason yeah it's fine yeah it's great
it's like could use a better camera but
it's okay
yeah so one question was from a start-up
founder Chris Giordano yes any tips on
how to engage with influencers when
you're a very early-stage startup with
little or no money yeah
my biggest tip would be to offer
something that would make it it's got to
be a win-win for everyone involved so
even if you're not a startup even if
you're a company who's just not into
influencer marketing yet the whole idea
of creators working with companies is
obviously they need to the financial
support but also they want to be able to
make something that they wouldn't have
otherwise been able to make so whether
they give an access to something or
they're given a behind-the-scenes look
at something something like that you
don't have to like always pay them a lot
but like if you can get something like
that that suddenly their audience is
really into that's a win - so if that's
a win for the audience because I got a
better video that's the one for the
creator because they could make
something better that their audience now
gets to see and that's a win for the
company involved because now your stuff
is in front of a new audience so even if
you don't have the financial means to
just dive right into paying for ads you
can always offer something that can make
a video better and if you do like I also
notice a lot that not a lot of research
is done they kind of just have like this
list of tech channels and they just sort
of they just blank it and carpet
everyone the same email but if you
really want to work with a certain
creator for a certain reason make that
clear like that like you've watched
their videos and you notice a theme and
you think there's some potential for a
yeah building on something there that's
worth expounding upon so in addition to
this kind of influencer marketing where
do you see the future of individual
creators supporting themselves as
business going we give this question
most often in relation to podcasts right
how are
people gonna monetize if you can shake
here on YouTube especially lately just
because of where we're at and I get it
the easy answer is just just be PC and
be super clean and never never push any
buttons but like a certain point that's
not where you want to be kind of want to
be able to explore and do different
things yeah so you you have to diversify
your income that's the simple answer so
at this point I can use myself as an
example the channel obviously has ads on
it and that's been one version of income
as an independent creator there's also a
something called affiliate income where
you you talk about products a lot you
might as well share the availability to
buy those products so Amazon has an
affiliate system B&H has an affiliate
system there's also a merged store this
is something not every creator can do
but if you can why not
I very recently super-late got into it
but like trying to make a sort of people
ask me all the time what sweatshirt I
was wearing in videos so I figured I
might as well offer a sweatshirt at some
point you can you can you can turn that
into sort of a fashion brand if you will
and just having different different ways
of of supporting the same thing where
they all sort of point back to the same
thing what about those paid
subscriptions or even oh yeah I don't
see how the patreon so at a certain
point you can ask dedicated viewers who
really want to support what you do
directly if they want to contribute more
oftentimes they won't have a problem
with that if they really like your work
or if your work isn't common I think a
lot of times if they feel like they can
just find what you're doing somewhere
else then there's no reason for them to
stick around or pay for it but if what
you do is like less frequent or it's
really high effort or it's not something
that that they're gonna find somewhere
else yeah and that will come from you
working on your craft real long time
then often times they'll have no problem
deciding they want to help you out cool
and when it comes to you now that you're
a pretty successful channel what are
those ratios look like do you know off
the top of your head yeah I would say
the I'm still at a point where like the
YouTube ads are probably 40 40 to 50
percent the I don't do a whole lot of
sponsored stuff okay if I did that
number would be much higher but I think
right now sponsored stuff is probably
about 20% so 40 20 and then affiliate
stuff being another 10 so where I like
what's 70 now so I guess yeah YouTube
ads is probably bigger YouTube ads
probably 50% of what the the streams
look like hmm so you think your biggest
problem right now as a creator is like
figuring out how to do these more
difficult things yeah yeah I mean I'm
still on that quest of production like I
know my videos can be better like there
there's still always a gap between like
a great YouTube video and a movie of
course like it everyone can tell a
YouTube video from a movie and
everything but like I ideally that like
seamless like production where I can
tell the story I want show what I want
to show and not have any barriers in the
way as far as production that would be
ideal
that's probably my biggest challenge and
then one of those like I feel like an
octopus like chopping off one of my arms
and handing it to someone but like
having other people who can edit
having other people who can do set
design and can contribute on things that
I'm doing 8 things at once I wish
someone else could take the load off me
that kind of stuff is also a challenge
for me right now but that's something
I'm working on - that's interesting
all right so I guess my last question
for you then matcha is a your long your
long term goal like what are you
shooting for in 10 15 years well 10
years I'll be 35 over the hill yeah man
no longer relevant I guess a long-term
goal as much as I
I've said before like I don't have
long-term goals but most of my my
forward-thinking is like two to three
years out like where I want the company
to be where I want the
in process to be but I guess if you look
10 years out that's more of like like
media company type stuff like ideally
there's a there's a YouTube channel
maybe a second YouTube channel there's a
podcast there's a there's a production
aspect to it where you can you can
assist with other channels things like
that
and I think it's nowhere near on its way
there yet I think I'm still so focused
on the actual video side of it and and
making that what I really want it to be
that I haven't really set foot in these
other categories yet but maybe someday
soon you're gonna make a movie that's
funny you asked that
like long-form stuff long-form being
like 45-minute an hour long videos has
been fascinating to me on YouTube
because it's been proven to be not that
unreasonable especially lately so who
the Shane Dawson's of the world like
like really hidden at home I like to
make a movie yeah cool yeah all right
man thanks for coming in thanks for
having me
you